jean-luc godard changed how we write and
direct he changed how we shoot and edit
he changed how we use music and sound
even title cards he didn't just break
the rules he he ran him over in a stolen
car and then threw it in reverse and
backed over them to make sure they were
dead
Godard once said every film should have
a beginning a middle and an end but not
necessarily in that order
and in keeping with that spirit we would
like to propose our toast to him now
even though we're not done with this
tribute
mr. Godard in your long career as a
filmmaker and provocateur let's be
honest you have said things that have
offended pretty much everybody in this
room at least once you have also said
really snarky things about Hollywood and
the Oscars but then again so has
everybody in this room at least once
none of that has deterred this board of
governors from bestowing upon you the
the highest honor we can for artistic
achievement let's be clear this ain't
the Hersholt Humanitarian Award this
someone had to say it of course it's the
writer this is an honorary Oscar I
shouldn't be saying this to me there's
an honorary Oscar for your brilliance
your innovation there you are
and your unapologetic orneriness you
have enriched our artform immeasurably
it's impossible to imagine contemporary
cinema without your influence and for
that and all the great films we say
Thank You mr. Godard wherever you are
you